هذا موقف حي الشجاعيه الموقف المركزي الذي
كان يربط ما بين منطقه جباليا وما بين
منطقه حي الزيتون وهذه منطقه سوق حي
الشجاعيه المركزي الذي دمر بالكامل الذي
يتغذى عليه ويزور هذا السوق الكثير من
المواطنون من مختلف المناطق الغربيه
والشرقيه هذه المنطقه اصبحت منطقه مدمره
بعد ان كانت منطقه حيويه جدا ومكتظ
بالمحال التجاريه هنا يحاول بعض التجار
والمواطنون انتشال ما تبقى من هذا الدمار
هذه هذا السوق المركزي الذي ندخل اليه هذا
سوق حي الشجاعيه الذي معروف ومشهور ب تنوع
البضائع في داخله وكثير من المحال على
مختلف انواعها لكن قوات الاحتلال اصرت على
تدمير هذا الحي بعدما شكل درجه من الصمود
في وجه قوات الاحتلال وكان عقبه كبيره في
دخول قوات الاحتلال الى هذا الحي وتاذي
كثيرا بعد دخوله الى هذا الحي حتى انسحب
لواء جو
اني من هذا المكان هذا احد ابراج الارسال
التي دمرت وكان واضح سلوك قوات الاحتلال
منذ بدايه هذا هذه الحرب على تدمير وا
اعطاب وا منع اي نوع من الاتصالات حتى
اتصالات الانترنت ومنعت الشركات التي تختص
بهذا المجال ان تقوم بعملها والله دخلت
قبل هيك على المنطقه هي شجعيه وبنشتري كنا
منها لكن بصراحه شغله سيئه جدا جدا جدا
انا عاجزه عن عن التعبير عاجزه عن الكلام
اي بصراحه القلب بيبكي ق ق قبل ال العيون
يعني هذا شارع الشواه الذي كانت فيه
بنايات عريقه وقديمه وهو من اقدم الاحياء
السكنيه المتواجده في منطقه حي الشجاعيه
هذا الحي اصبح حيا مدمرا وممرات ما بين
ممرات الاهلي التابعه للاحتلال ما بين
ركام هذه المنازل التي دمرت بعد قصف عنيف
ونسف شوارع مضروبه في بعض دمار خيال يعني
في الافلام الود مابين والله العظيم ما
عارفين ايش احنا مسوي لهم اقسم بالله
المدارس فوق بعض والدور فوق بعض يعني
بتمشي فوق الركام عشان تصل دارك مجر يعني
مخليين فيش
حياه الحيوان عزاكم الله بيقدرش يمشي فيه
المناطق
هذ كانه زلزال ضرب المكان طبعا بعد 76 يوم
من الحرب انا لم اصل طبعا بعمل في الطواقم
الطبيه اجيت اتفقد البيت بعد ما انسحب
قوات الاحتلال ودمر البيت انا بعرفش البيت
يعني لا في لا مقاومه بيت امن يؤوي اسرتي
واطفالي
واولادي تدمر طبعا لا يصلح للسكن طبعا
الشقه اللي فوق محروقه كل الاساس محروق ط
بتقدرش كمان تطلع فوق بسبب الدمار الهائل
في الدرج
ايش بدي اقول غير حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل انسحبت قوات الاحتلال من منطقه حي
الشجاعيه مخلفه كل هذا الدمار حتى باتت
هذه المنطقه غير صالحه للحياه اسماعيل
الغول قناه
الجزيره